SCP-682 Vs SCP-170. Can the
ultimate molecular superglue
pin the Hard to Destroy Reptile down for good?
The SCP-170 glue was laced onto a series of metal
chains, with the hope of confining rather than
executing the monster. The tissue sample was
promising, and things proceeded from there.
682 was sedated and wrapped with chains
which were then connected to the ground.
Initially, when 682 woke up, it thrashed around
and tried to escape. However, its attempts were
futile. But before the researchers could
start patting themselves on the back,
682 began to grow, until it reached such
a size that the chains simply popped off.
The leading theory as to how this worked
was that it hadn’t technically grown,
but increased the distance between its particles,
shattering the molecular bond created by SCP-170.